>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington, D.C.
[ Music ]
>> Katherine Blood: I wonder if you
wouldn't mind jumping over to some
of the pieces that are
from a part of the world
that you're very directly
engaged with in your history.
So from La Raza Graphics, we have
a couple of things over here.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
From La Raza Graphic Center.
>> Katherine Blood: Yeah.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Right?
From La Raza Graphic--
>> Katherine Blood: Screen
Print Center, exactly.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: La Raza
Graphic Center, Printing Center.
So this particular--
>> Katherine Blood: You were there.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: I was there.
>> Katherine Blood: This
is your neighborhood.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: I was
there in the neighborhood.
So the poster we have over here,
it's a bit of a place I remember
that was on 16th and Mission.
And this is a 1982 poster
from La Raza Graphic Center.
And it says right there they
do typesetting, silkscreen,
illustration, logo
design, cartoons, and on.
And I remember going to
La Raza Graphics just
to get some flyers done or to
just say hello Herbert Siguenza,
Malaquias Montoya, and
was it Linda Lucero?
>> Katherine Blood: Linda
Lucero, Juan Fuentes.
And they're pictured in
this image in this studio.
And so you've been to this place
and you know these artists.
And they printed the
poster that we've put along
with the scene from the studio.
And this is very personal,
something that you helped to build.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yes.
>> Katherine Blood: El
Tecolote, bilingual newspaper.
And you did something specific.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Yeah.
So this El Tecolote [inaudible].
So this El Tecolote,
beautiful poster
that was done at La Raza Graphics.
And it's celebrating the El
Tecolote 8th Anniversary.
>> Katherine Blood: So 1978.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: 1978.
>> Katherine Blood: 1978.
And I was there in 19-- I kind
of got into the Mission District.
This is what takes place in
San Francisco, in the Bay Area.
And with Francisco Rincon.
And I kind of teamed up
with many good friends
in the Mission District,
Victor Martinez
and La Handra Muhia [phonetic],
Roberto Valdez [phonetic],
and we're many good
friends [foreign phrase].
And we, Francisco I believe, put
together the event to propose
that we form Tecolote
[foreign phrase],
kind of like a literary insert.
Tecolote means paper [inaudible],
so really open arms and
invited us to do so.
And then we began to call
on poets from the Bay Area
and throughout California
United States and Latin America
to send us poetry and art.
And we did that for
a number of years.
And Francisco Rincon has
always been at the heart of it.
Also Horgeta [phonetic].
And Susan Martinez from San
Jose did a lot of the art.
And many more good people.
So these are very-- I'm
very close to these posters.
I'm so glad you have them here.
>> Katherine Blood: It's part
of an amazing collection.
Mission Graphic [inaudible]
collection is more
than 1,000 prints and posters.
We were talking about how
it's many different art forms
and many different artists.
So the posters are
reflecting activism,
but they're also reflecting--
it's a whole universe.
So they're reflecting the community.
They're reflecting this
party that's in celebration
of the 8th anniversary
of the newspaper.
Dance, music, poetry
readings, there's a poster
for a poetry reading that you
participated in in this collection.
So this is just very rich.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Many
of the people, you know,
sometimes people talk
about an art movement
or a poetry movement
or a social movement.
Well, this is what it is, you know?
It's people working out of
a cultural center or out
of a small storefront like La Raza
Graphics, or have a smaller space
like El Tecolote [foreign phrase]
El Tecolote Community Newspaper,
bilingual newspaper,
Spanish and English,
and putting out some beautiful
posters and doing readings
and doing art and activism,
newspaper, stories, journalism,
and doing a little
business for the people
by creating silkscreens
of beautiful events.
So so many beautiful things.
And so I'm so happy.
And look at this right here.
>> Katherine Blood: This is--
this was an amazing experience.
I was invited to the print-making
studio/class that's in Quentin,
which I hadn't known this existed.
And this would have
been around 2008.
And the instructor, Katia [phonetic]
Macoa [phonetic] invited me.
And I sat and watched the
artists making linocut prints,
and I talked with them, and you've
selected a few things to show
from this portfolio, San
Quentin Art's portfolio,
and by a particular artist featuring
this artist Ronnie Goodman.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Ronnie Goodman.
>> Katherine Blood:
He continues to--
so these were prisoner
artists at the time.
Ronnie Goodman is now working in
California and exhibiting and,
you know, working actively
as an artist still.
But he's very, very talented.
It's very compelling
work, in my opinion.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's beautiful.
You know, I noticed that
Ronnie Goodman does a portrait
or includes an image of Frida
Kahlo in one of these prints.
>> Katherine Blood: Do
you want to share it?
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Oh, sure.
Let's share it.
And there's a figure with kind
of an angelic figure right here
with the big wings and he's kind
of sitting down facing down.
>> Katherine Blood:
And this is the artist.
It's a self-portrait.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
And this is the artist,
a self-portrait, Ronnie Goodman.
And this takes place in a
prison location, a prison space,
place of containment
without keys at the moment.
But there is the key of art.
And above--
>> Katherine Blood:
A way of being free.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
And here's Frida Kahlo,
an image of Frida Kahlo.
And I haven't seen
this kind of image
of Frida Kahlo to this very moment.
>> Katherine Blood: It's unique.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: It's
very unique, very unique.
And it's the night stars
and the black and white.
And very moving.
African-American artist.
>> Katherine Blood: That's right.
He's holding his paintbrushes.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
Holding his paintbrushes.
So I'm really moved by--
>> Katherine Blood: That's the key.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
That's the key.
Beautiful.
And that's the key that we're
inviting all of you to use
because you already have that key
to express yourselves, to write,
to view these beautiful materials
from [foreign name], our prints
and photographs, the vision
here at the Library of Congress
that we want to bring out to you.
And La Casa de Colores'
annual long-year project.
And I just can't believe it,
all these good materials,
and Ronnie Goodman.
And right here in front of us--
>> Katherine Blood:
Elizabeth Catlett.
So one of the great-- and
I'm going to show this
so you can sort of look at it too.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera: Okay.
>> Katherine Blood:
Elizabeth Catlett is one
of our great canonical
American artists.
And so she was-- I want
to say she was in her 80s
when she made this in 2005.
And it's very cool because all
of the color is digital and all
of the blocks for the
framework is lithography.
So she's sort of straddling
the old and the new.
It's called Gossip.
This piece is called Gossip.
And this is just this
beautiful little intimate scene.
And she's known often for
portraying women, strong women,
and this is a very
contemporary expression of that.
>> Juan Felipe Herrera:
And they look
like they're having
a serious exchange,
something that has taken place.
I can't believe it.
I love it.
>> Katherine Blood: I love it too.
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.